what's going on guys this is rob and
with she-hulk coming out i figured we
would cover what is really the most
popular moment in the history of
she-hulk comics which is when she meets
the living tribunal so this is one of
those moments and it's kind of
interesting here it's one of those
moments when dan slot unofficially
establishes a role for she-hulk that's
predicated on previous information but
the first thing we basically do here is
we pick up on titan and what is
essentially the trial of eros and the
reason why is because the argument being
created here is that with eros having
the ability to essentially manipulate
the emotional states of others around
him that he's been using that for
selfish means specifically he's been
using that to get girls and the argument
is that he's abusing his power in such a
way to where it's essentially a
violation now of course his argument is
no that's not necessarily the case and
so what it is is happening here is him
being tried for his previous actions now
there are a couple things that i want to
specify here the first thing is that
what you have is him being brought to
what's referred to as the judgment chair
by way of captain marvel as well as moon
dragon now this is not the captain
marvel that you know this is before
kelly sue deconyx run which basically
means this is phi level those of you
guys who don't know who phyla vel is
she's amazing she's probably the best
character that the marvel cinematic
universe has not brought in yet she's an
absolute badass this story doesn't do
her justice if you want to see
philavelle at her absolute best
annihilation conquest is the story that
you want that story is amazing but eros
himself unlike in the mcu for those of
you guys who are unfamiliar with the
comics who don't know about that unlike
the mcu he's not a robot in the comics
instead he's an actual biological being
with the power to manipulate the
emotions of others for moon dragon
that's heather douglas she is the
daughter of drax the destroyer who was
basically taken to uh to titan and
raised there following her perceived
death and she's actually a ridiculously
powerful telepath she also turns into a
literal dragon at one point in time
actually during annihilation conquest is
when that happens but it is one of those
wild things the thing here though is
that while we are covering issue number
12 this technically starts in issue
number seven and the reason why this is
important is because this trial
originates on earth whereby eros is
again quite literally being put on trial
for using his powers on a woman who in
turn because of the nature of his
ability to manipulate her emotional
state was romantically drawn towards him
so almost kind of against her will is
really what it is now initially she hulk
doesn't realize this is what was going
on at least jennifer walters in her
human form doesn't grasp this but when
the statement's made by that witness she
recalls on the time she spent with eros
when the two of them slept together when
she was on the avengers and then in
questioning him uh did you you use your
powers on me when the two of us slept
together he basically cuts the feet
right he just dodges the question cuts
the feed and then tries to flee earth
she-hulk catches up to him beats the
hell out of him and then basically takes
him prisoner at which point he is
transported to saturn's moon titan by
his father mentor and that's basically
where this picks up the other part of
that is that in issues 7 8 and 9 and 10
and 11 to a degree you basically get the
introduction of the magistrate now the
nature of the magistrate again this is
really a uh a dance slot creation over
the years in marvel comics when it came
to the living tribunal passing judgment
it was just a tribunal doing it that was
basically it the living tribunal would
show up in a universe where there was
some kind of a mystical imbalance i.e
whatever plot device a writer wanted to
invoke for the living tribunal being
there in the first place and then the
tribunal would pass its judgment and
that would be the end of that over the
years or at least originally the
tribunal would only show up when it came
to like cosmic level threats so things
like the infinity gauntlet storyline uh
doctor strange releasing zom and the
really the initial appearance of the
living tribunal in marvel comics
different things along those lines one
of the things you'll hear a lot from
comic book fans and it's to justifiable
gripe is that the living tribunal has
kind of become a bit of a punching bag
as time has gone on he's become far less
serious and significant than the living
tribunal used to be but at this point in
time it was kind of the middle ground
and this is one of those stories that
starts moving things in that direction
and so when this trial initially
commences the magistrates show up and
then they basically tell mentor this
whole trial is a farce and it is right
the the trial that's being put on by
mentor here is less about holding star
fox accountable for the things that he'd
done and more about just clearing his
name that's basically it just literally
trying to save his son very human in
that way but because the whole thing is
a farce and because it's all a big sham
the magistrati demand that at least
somebody on earth be available to
essentially witness this trial albeit in
a you know non-biased manner but
somebody still be there hence the reason
why she hulk is brought by what's
basically a recorder a universal device
designed to literally record events
across the universe and then brought to
uh titan's moon in order to observe
everything now initially she says no
once she realizes that a star fox who's
being put on trial she rejects it she
says i'm not going to have anything to
do with this and that's when the living
tribunal appears and basically it tells
her no right you swore an oath to serve
us to promote universal law meaning that
your your loyalty to the laws is not
just based on what goes on on earth but
it's also you're essentially a
magistrate you are a member of my group
that i send into different universes in
order to uphold my will basically
whenever i'm too busy and you have to do
that now right and that's the thing like
initially she hulk is like no no i can't
do that because
star fox and i slept together and i
think he uses powers on me in order to
achieve that and i can't be unbiased
here but the response to the tribunal is
your relations to him are irrelevant it
doesn't matter right all that matters is
that you represent us the three faces of
justice now the cool thing about that is
it is a little bit of a reminder of the
role the tribunal plays although by this
point in time if you're reading marvel
comics you know exactly what the
tribunal is about hence the benefit of
this for people who don't read comics
that the half shrouded face represents
vengeance the unmasked face represents
equity and then there is the hidden face
which the living tribunal has and the
hidden face basically is revealed to
she-hulk when it says hear my magistrate
look look upon my last face and she-hulk
sees herself and the response to the
tribunal is it is the face of necessity
the cosmic mirror which reminds us to
always judge others as we would have
ourselves judged no matter what the cost
to do what is required of us to do what
must be done now here's the thing about
the living tribunal whenever people
reference this particular comic they
oftentimes get it confused with silver
surfer vol 3 issue number 31 uh which
basically expanded on the nature of the
living tribunal's faces in the sense
that it does have three right equity
vengeance necessity but could
potentially have a fourth face which
would have been the face of the stranger
now the significance of that has never
really been explored by marvel comics it
was just a possibility that could have
been there and that was basically it uh
beyond that this is just one of those
things where very rarely do we ever see
the tribunal one address a mortal
directly and two reveal what its hidden
face actually looks like but the
significance of this is that with this
addressing having come to she-hulk by
the living tribunal she in turn responds
to the trial right she says okay fine
i've been directly told to travel to
this place now one of the things to know
is and really one of the questions to
ask is what if she has still said no the
tribunal likely would have forced her to
go anyway since that was her role as
part of the magistrati or she would he
would have stripped her of her title and
that would have basically been it such
as it is the story just progresses in a
way without us really giving getting
that answer honestly we can offer our
own interpretation there but the fact
remains that with this whole situation
unfolding the way that it is you have
all these different people who basically
appear here to offer their own
explanations to uh to star fox really as
just observers or as people who are
character witnesses one of the first of
them is pip the troll now the reason for
this is pip the troll unlike what you
saw in the mcu where pip introduced eros
to the eternals the reality is that
pippa trolls relationship is more closer
in line with adam warlock and gamora
than anybody else but there was a point
in marvel really back during like the
late 80s and early 90s kind of the
golden age of marvel cosmic if you want
to call it that hip the troll was very
closely intertwined with eros himself
and in fact that's kind of the nature of
pip he sort of bounces around that's one
of the reasons why a lot of fans have a
very fond place in their hearts for jim
starlin's run because it was like cosmic
marvel before we really got cosmic
marvel and in all honesty we might go
back and cover that era of comics it's
just it's a really really cool point in
time but pip the troll actually makes
this passing remark to she-hulk as he
walks by he realizes she's not wearing
any underwear he's like going commando
huh brave choice and then she freaks out
and tries to attack him
but pip the troll inadvertently actually
offers testimony that that actually
condemns uh eros to a degree right when
he's just like man let me tell you about
eros right he's the greatest guy never
had a better time than i did when i was
hanging out with eros man the women
you'd be amazed what kind of women you
can find yourself surrounded by with
eros like i don't know what it is man
but for whatever reason this guy just
has the late the ladies just come to him
and inadvertently he actually reveals
that eros manipulates the emotional
states of the women around him in order
to get those women to become sexually
interested in him and so basically
divulging that he's like oh wait a
minute this whole trial is because he's
using his powers to get chicks to like
bang him right and people are like i
mean yeah and he's like okay so i'm out
uh i'll see you guys later
and he basically bails and so following
that you get a really really cool
instance where she-hulk steps up and
says i will testify in defense or at
least offer testimony on behalf of eros
now when i say testimony it's what you
would call passing for testimony here
the reality is that their their systems
of law are far more advanced than
humanities right like one because the
race is more advanced than two because
we as people are still kind of stupid
right i mean all things considered we're
not that bright and so the way this
works is that there's a kind of mental
projection that's given by way of both
she-hulk as well as eros and what it
does is it allows an observer somebody
like uh like moon dragon for example who
can act as an intermediary a telepathic
go-between that she can basically take
the memories of she-hulk and compare
them to the memories of eros in terms of
how they perceive things and what they
were thinking and basically use that to
verify its authenticity this really
comes to a head when the two of them
share a kind of mental link and what
we're told here is that the romantic
connection between the two was
legitimate that it was actually a legit
connection that she hulk was really
romantically interested in eros and eros
was romantically interested in she-hulk
and as a result of that the two of them
did sleep together out of a mutual
interest as opposed to eros manipulating
her and so as a result of that when the
questions asked like did you ever did
you ever like use your love powers on me
the response of eros is i did when you
were dating john jameson the son of jay
jonah jameson now that was one of the
the i guess bigger romantic exploits of
she-hulk the way the story was initially
told she-hulk just sort of fell out of
love with john jameson this was dan slot
coming back and explaining the reason
why that happened is because star fox
had manipulated she-hulk in order to
ensure that happened because from star
fox's perspective she-hulk was just
unhappy but she just didn't have the
gumption to pull the trigger she didn't
have the gumption to just break up with
him and walk away so star fox
effectively did it for her now the funny
thing about this is that she hulk was
very much interested in john jameson it
was just one their lives were starkly
different two it would have been
difficult to make that relationship work
and three she was still struggling with
the idea of dealing with her own issues
in terms of like the she-hulk jennifer
walters dichotomy and all that kind of
stuff so the reality here is her
struggles when it came to john jameson
had less to do with john and more to do
with herself it was just one of these
elements where she basically finds out
that her her withdrawing from jon was
due to a manipulation by star fox which
of course she lashes out and starts
attacking him now of course phi level
and moon dragons step in and this leads
to her attacking both of them and then
it's just like a three-way fight now the
cool thing about this this is one of the
things that i love so much these chicks
are op let me tell you something man
like between she-hulk and moon dragon
and phyla vel they could take all-comers
right there's almost no one that would
be able to stand against them minus like
super high level beings right franklin
richards gets pissed off and decides to
attack them yeah they're gonna die but
between these three right here i would
say they're they would be able to take
on most anybody who's out there so the
three of them fighting like that is no
small thing and that's why everybody
tries to stop them and calm them down
but then suddenly isaac the sentient
computer that's kind of the arbiter of
this entire trial brings everything to a
halt by saying that there's effectively
a portal that's opening up here and this
portal is leading to the arrival of
thanos and so as soon as he arrives
everybody stops right like literally
she-hulk moon dragon and philadelphia
are like oh we all we all have a truce
and they're like yeah because
everybody's suddenly on their guard
whenever thanos arrives it's usually
because he's gonna start wrecking things
right he's gonna start killing people
but the funny thing here is when he
shows up he's like look i'm not here to
attack or kill anybody i'm here to
testify on behalf of my brother star fox
right on behalf of eros offer my
testimony here in order to help this guy
get off and so what ends up happening is
once he sits down and you have
essentially the mental link that's
created between star fox and thanos and
then moon moondragon you get this moment
from when they were little kids and that
what had happened here is that thanos
had basically found himself with a bit
of a pet and then ultimately with this
pet that he had it ended up dying he
actually ended up killing it by accident
not realizing how strong he was and eros
came to his aid and tried to talk him
down and saying look you didn't mean to
kill it everything's okay like it's it's
okay it's not a great big huge thing
sometimes these things happen and where
thanos rebuked the idea of death and
hated the concept of death and didn't
quite understand why things had to die
the response of eros is like death is a
part of life thanos it's just the nature
of things value is given to the things
we love because we know we won't have
those things forever whether we lose
them before our life ends or we lose
them when our life ends the time we
spend with those in the attachments we
make that's what makes life worth living
and so using his powers he basically
manipulates him and he literally says i
told you that death was a part of life
that you should welcome it and that you
should embrace death with all your heart
and so the statement of thanos is that
is how i became the way i was that's how
i became the person that i am is because
literally star fox used his powers to
convince me that i should learn to love
death now here's the thing about that
this was dan's slot doing his thing and
honestly the artwork does not help the
credibility of this story at all uh but
that was all completely redone right
that this this whole thing with like
thanos in his origin and star fox
tricked him into loving mr steath this
was all totally redone with thanos
rising which is the single greatest
thanos origin story ever told by marvel
also because it's really one of the only
ones that exists out there but basically
actually reveals that mistress death had
been manipulating thanos since he was a
little kid but the thing about this is
that it's really revealed that's the
basis behind thanos now following that
the story basically unfolds and you know
the euros ends up getting off and so on
and so forth and the day is saved yada
yada right that happens in the next
issue that's not overly important right
the important thing here is that's what
happens when when she-hulk meets the
living tribunal as a member of his
majestrati uh and then we of course get
a sort of a sort of side companion with
the origin of thanos in terms of how it
was that he became who he was so having
said that guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace